The following
content is provided
under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help MIT
OpenCourseWare continue
to offer high quality
educational resources for free.
To make a donation or to
view additional materials
from hundreds of MIT courses,
visit MIT OpenCourseWare
at ocw.mit.edu.
PROFESSOR: So today,
let me remind you,
for the convenience
of also the people
that weren't here
last time, we don't
need too much of what
we did last time, except
to know, more or
less, what's going on.
We were solving central
potential problems
in which you have a potential
that just depends on r.
And at the end of the
day, the wave functions
were shown to take the
form of a radial part
and an angular part with
the spherical harmonic here.
The radial part was
very conveniently
presented as a U
function divided by r.
That's another function, but
the differential equation for U
is nice.
It takes the form of a
1-dimensional Schrodinger
equation for a particle
under the influence
of an effective potential.
This potential,
effective potential,
has the potential that you
have in your Hamiltonian
plus an extra term, a barrier.
It's a potential that
grows as r goes to 0,
so it's a barrier that
explodes at r equals 0.
And this being the
effective potential that
enters into this 1-dimensional
Schrodinger equation,
we made some observations
about this function U.
The normalization of
this wave function
is guaranteed if the integral of
U squared over r is equal to 1.
So that's a pretty nice thing.
U squared meaning absolute
value squared of U.
And we also noticed that U
must go like r to the l plus 1
near r going to 0.
So those were the
general properties of U.
I'm trying to catch
up with notes.
I hope to put some
notes out today.
But this material, in fact,
you can find parts of it
in almost any book.
It will just be presented
a little differently.
But this is not
very unusual stuff.
Now, the diagram that I wanted
to emphasize to you last time
was that if you're
trying to discuss
the spectrum of a
central state potential,
you do it with a
diagram in which you
list the energies
as a function of l.
And it's like a histogram
in which for l equals 0,
you have to solve some
1-dimensional Schrodinger
equation.
This 1-dimensional
Schrodinger equation
will have a bound state
spectrum that is non-degenerate.
So for l equal 0, there
will be one solution,
two solutions, three.
I don't know how many before
the continuous spectrum sets in,
or if there is a
continuous spectrum.
But there are some solutions.
For l equal 1, there will
be some other solutions.
For l equal 2, there might
And that depends on which
problem you are solving.
In general, there's no rhyme
or reason in this diagram,
except that the lowest energy
state for each level goes up.
And that's because the
potential goes up and up
as you increase l.
Notice this is totally positive.
So whatever potential
you have, it's
just going up as you increase l.
So the ground
state should go up.
The ground state
energy should go up.
So this diagram looks like this.
We also emphasized
that for every l,
there are 2l plus 1 solutions
obtained by varying M,
because M goes
from l to minus l.
Therefore, this
bar here represents
a single multiplate of l equals
1, therefore three states.
This is a single multiplate of
l equals 1, three more states.
Here is five
states, five states,
but only one l equal 1
multiplate, one l equal
1 multiplate, 1, 1.
There are no cases
in which you have
two multiplates because that
would contradict our known
statement that the spectrum of
the potential of bound states
in one dimensions
is non-degenerate.
So that was one thing we did.
And the other thing
that we concluded
that ties up with what
I want to talk now
was a discussion of the free
particle, free particle.
And in the case
of a free particle
you say, well, so
what are you solving?
Well, we're solving
for solutions
that have radial symmetry.
So they are functions
of r [INAUDIBLE]
angular distribution.
So what do you find is UEl
of r is equal to rJl of kr,
as we explained, where these
were the spherical Bessel
functions.
And those are not as bad as
the usual Bessel functions,
not that complicated.
They're finite
series constructed
with sines and cosines, so
these are quite tractable.
And that was for
a free particle.
So we decided that
we would solve
the case of an infinite
spherical well, which
is a potential V of r, which is
equal to 0 if r is less than a,
and infinity if r is
greater or equal than a.
It's a small-- well, a
is whatever size it is.
It's a cavity, spherical
cavity where you can live.
And outside you can't be there.
This is the analog of
the infinite square
well in one dimension.
But this is in three dimensions.
An infinite
spherical well should
be imagined as some sort of hole
in the material and electrons
or particles can move inside
and nothing can escape this.
So this is a hollow thing.
So this is a classic problem.
You would say this must
be as simple to solve
as the infinite square well.
And no, it's more complicated.
Not conceptually much more
complicated, but mathematically
more work.
You will consider some aspects
of the finite spherical
well in the homework.
The finite square
well, you remember,
is a bit more complicated.
You can't solve it exactly.
The finite spherical
well, of course,
you can't solve exactly either.
But you will look at
some aspects of it,
the most famous result
of which is the statement
that while any attractive
potential in one dimension
has a bound state
in three dimensions.
An attractive potential,
so a finite spherical well,
may not have a bound state,
even a single bound state.
So that's a very
interesting thing
that you will understand in
the homework in several ways.
You will also understand some
things about delta functions,
that they're important.
So we'll touch base with that.
So that's as far as I got
last time and just a review.
If there are any
questions, don't be shy
if you weren't here and
you have a question.
Yes.
AUDIENCE: Is there any reason to
expect [INAUDIBLE] intuitively
should be like [INAUDIBLE]?
PROFESSOR: Well, the reason,
intuitively the reason
is basically the conspiracy
between this UEl,
as I was saying,
UEl as r goes to 0
goes like r to the l plus 1.
So first of all, this
potential is very repulsive.
Is that right?
So that tends to ruin things.
So you could say, oh, well,
this thing is probably not
going to get anything
because near r equal 0,
you're being repelled.
But you cay say, no, let's
look at that l equal 0.
So you don't have
that, so just V of r.
But we take l equals 0--
I'm sorry, U here, U of El
has to go like that.
So actually, U will
vanish for r equals 0.
So the effective potential
for the 1-dimensional problem
may look like a finite square
well, that is like that.
But the wave function has
to vanish on this side.
Even though you would say,
it's a finite spherical well,
why does it have to
vanish Here well,
it's the unusual behavior
of this U function.
So the wave function that
you can sort of imagine
must vanish here.
So in order to
get a bound state,
it has to have enough
time to sort of curve
so that it can fall, and it's
sometimes difficult to do it.
So basically, it's the fact
that the wave function has
to vanish at the origin, the
U wave function has to vanish.
Now, the whole wave
function doesn't
vanish because
it's divided by r.
But the U does.
So it's the reason why you don't
have bound states in general.
And then there's also funny
things like a delta function.
You would say, well, a
3-dimensional delta function,
how many bound states do
you get, or what's going on?
With a 1-dimensional
delta function,
you have one bound
state, and that's it.
With a 3-dimensional delta
function, as you will find,
it's [INAUDIBLE]
is rather singular,
and you tend to get
infinitely many bound states.
And you cannot even calculate
them because they fall off all
the way through r and go
to minus infinity energy.
It's a rather strange situation.
All right.
Any other questions?
So let's do this
infinite spherical well.
Now, the reason we did
the free particle first
was that inside here,
this is all free,
so the solutions will
be sort of simple.
Nevertheless, we can begin with
looking at the differential
equation directly for inside.
So r less than a, you would
have minus d second UEl
over d rho squared,
actually, plus l times l
plus 1 over rho
squared UEl equals
UEl, where rho is equal to kr.
And k-- I'm sorry, I
didn't write it there--
is 2mE over h squared as usual.
So here I didn't say what k was.
That was 2mE over h squared.
And this doesn't quite look
like the differential equation
you have here.
Well, V of r is 0
for r less than a,
so you just have this term.
The h squared's
over 2m and the E
have been rescaled
by changing r to rho.
So the differential
equation becomes
simple and looking like this.
So that was a manipulation that
was done in detail last time,
but you can redo it.
Now, this, as I mentioned,
is not a simple differential
equation.
If you didn't have this, it
would have a power solution.
If you don't have this,
it's just a sine or cosines.
But if you have
both, it's Bessel.
So having a
differential with two
derivatives, 1 over
rho squared and 1,
brings you into
Bessel territory.
Anyway, this is
the equation that,
in fact, is solved
by these functions
because it's a free
Schrodinger equation,
and you can take
it for l equal 0.
This is the only
case we can do easily
without looking up
any Bessel functions
or anything like that.
You then have d second UE0
d rho squared is equal UE0.
And therefore, UE0 goes like A
sine of rho plus B cosine rho.
Rho is kr.
UEl must behave like
r to the l plus 1,
so UE0 must behave like r.
So for this thing to
behave, must behave like r.
So it must behave like
rho as rho goes to 0.
Therefore, this term
cannot be there.
The only solution is
UE0 is equal to sine
of rho, which is kr.
So UE0 of r must
be of this form.
Then in order to have a
solution of the 1-dimensional
Schrodinger equation, it's
true that the potential
becomes infinite for r equal a.
So that is familiar.
It's not the point r
equal 0 that is unusual.
r equal a, this must vanish.
So we need that UE0
of a will equal to 0.
So this requires k equal some
kn so that kna is equal to n pi.
So for k is equal to kn,
where kn,a is equal to n pi,
a multiple of pi, then the
wave function will vanish at r
equals a.
So easy enough.
We've found the values of k.
This is quite analogous to
the infinite square well.
And now the energies
from this formula En
will be equal to h squared
kn squared over 2m.
And it's convenient,
of course, to divide
by ma squared so that
you have kna squared.
So the energies are h
squared over 2ma squared.
Here we have n pi squared.
I'll put them like this.
En,0 for l equal
0, En,l's energies.
Now, if you want to
remember something
about this, of course,
all these constants
are kind of irrelevant.
But the good thing
is that this carries
the full units of energy.
And you know in a system
with length scale a,
this is the typical energy.
So the energies are essentially
that typical energy times
n squared pi squared.
So it's convenient to define,
in general, En,l to be En,l,
for any l that you
may be solving,
divided by h squared
over 2ma squared.
So that this thing has no units.
And it tells you for any
level, the calligraphic E,
roughly how much bigger it
is than the natural energy
scale of your problem.
So it's a nice definition.
And in this way, we've learned
that En,0 is equal to n pi
squared.
And a few values of this are
E1,0 about 9,869 [INAUDIBLE],
E2,0 equal 39,478, and
E3,0 is equal 88,826.
Not very dramatic
numbers, but they're
still kind of interesting.
So what else about this problem?
Well, we can do
the general case.
Let me erase a little here
so that we can proceed.
The general case
is based on knowing
the zeroes of this
spherical Bessel function.
So this is something that the
first one you can do easily.
The zeroes of J1
of rho are points
at which tan rho
is equal to rho.
That is a short calculation
if you ever want to do it.
That's not that
difficult, of course,
but you have to
do it numerically.
So the zeroes of
the Bessel functions
are known and are tabulated.
You can find them on the web,
little programs that do it
on the web and give you
[? directly those ?] zeroes.
So how are they defined?
Basically, people define Zn,l to
be the n-th zero with n equals
1 like that of Jl.
So more precisely, Jl
of Zn,l is equal to 0.
And all the Z and l's
are different from 0.
There's a trivial zero at 0.
And nevertheless,
that is not counted.
It's just too trivial
for it to be interesting.
So these numbers, Z and
l, are basically it.
Why?
Because what you
need is, if you're
looking for the l-th solution,
you need UEl of a equal 0.
And UEa of that equal 0 means
that you need kn,l times a be
equal to Zn,l.
So kn,l is the value of k.
And just like we quantized
here, we had kn, well,
if you have various
l's, put the kn,l.
So for every value of l, you
have kn,l's that are given
by this.
And the energy's like this.
Let me copy what this would be.
En,l would be En,l
over this ratio.
And En,l h squared, well,
let me do it this way.
I'm sorry.
En,l would be h squared
kn,l over 2ma squared,
over 2m like that.
Then you multiply
by a squared again.
So you get kn,l a
squared over 2ma squared.
So what you learn from
this is that En,l,
you divide this by that, is
just kn,l times a, which is Zm,l
squared.
So that's the simple result.
The En,l's are just the squares
of the zeroes of the Bessel
function.
So you divide it again
by h squared over 2ma,
and that's all that was left.
So you need to know the
zeroes of the Bessel function.
And there's one,
you might say, well,
what for do I care about this?
But it's kind of
nice to see them.
So Z1,1 is equal to 4.49
Z2,1 is equal to 7.72,
and Z3,1 is 10.90, numbers that
may have no rhyme or reason.
Now, you've done
here l equals 1.
Of course, it continues
down, down, down.
You can continue with the first
zero, first nontrivial zero,
second nontrivial zero,
third nontrivial zero,
and it goes on.
The energies the squares.
So the squared goes like 20.19.
This goes like 59.7.
And this goes like 119 roughly.
Then you have the other zeroes.
First zero for l equals
2, that is 5.76 roughly.
Second zero for l equals
to 2 is 9.1 roughly.
And if you square those to
see those other energies,
you would get, by
squaring, 33.21 and 82.72.
And finally, let me do one more.
Z1,3, the first zero of the
l equal 3, and the Z2,3,
the second zero,
are 6.99 and 10.4,
which when squared give
you 48.83 and 108.5.
OK.
Why do you want to
see those numbers?
I think the reason
you want to see
them is to just look at
the diagram of energies,
which is kind of interesting.
So let's do that.
So here I'll plot
energies, and here I put l.
And now I need a big diagram.
Here I'll put the
curly energies.
And here is 10, 20, 30,
40, 50, 60-- and now
I need the next blackboard,
let's see, we're 60,
let's see, more or less,
here is about right--
70, 80, 90, 100, 110.
How far do I need?
120, ooh, OK, 120.
There we go.
So just for the fun of it.
Look at them to
see how they look,
if you can see any pattern.
So the first energy was
986, so that's roughly here.
That's l equals 0
is the first state.
Second is 39.47, so it's
a little below here.
Next is 88.82, so we
are here, roughly.
Then we go l equals 1.
What are the values?
This one's 20.19.
L equals 1, 20.19,
so we're around here.
Then 59.7 is almost 60.
And then 119, so that's why
we needed to go that high.
So here we are.
And then l equals 3, you
have 48.83, so that's 50.
I'm sorry, l equals 2.
48.83.
A little lower than that.
No, I'm sorry.
It's 33.21.
I'm misreading that.
33 over here.
And then 82.72, so we are here.
And then l equals
3, we have 48.83,
so that was the one
I wanted, and 108.5.
That's it, and there's
no pattern whatsoever.
The zeroes never match.
The only thing that is
true is that 0, 1, 2, 3,
they were ascending
as we predicted.
But no level matches
with any other level.
If you were trying to say, OK,
this potential is interesting,
is special, it has magic to
it, a spherical square well,
it doesn't seem to have
anything to it, in fact.
It's totally random.
I cannot prove for you,
but it's probably true,
and probably not
impossible to prove,
that these zeroes
are never the same.
No l and l prime will
have the same zero.
No degeneracy ever occurs
that needs an explanation.
For example, this state could
have ended up equal to this one
or equal to this one,
and it doesn't happen.
And that's OK,
because at this level,
we would not be able to
predict why it happened.
We actually, apart from the fact
that this a round, nice box,
what symmetries does
it have, that box,
except rotational symmetry?
Nothing all that dramatic.
So you would say, OK, let's
look for a problem, which we'll
deal now, that does have a
more surprising structure,
and let's try to figure it out.
Let's try the three dimensional
harmonic oscillator.
So 3D SHO.
Isotropic.
What is the potential?
It's 1/2 m omega
squared x squared
for x plus y squared plus z
squared, all the same constant.
So it's 1/2 m omega
squared r squared.
You would say, this
potential may or may not
be nicer than the
spherical well,
but actually, it
is extraordinarily
symmetric in a way that
the spherical well is not.
So we'll see why is that.
Let's look at the
states of this.
Now, we're going to
do it with numerology.
Everything will be
kind of numerology
here because I don't
want to calculate
things for this problem.
So first thing, how
you build the spectrum?
H is equal to h bar omega
N1 plus N2 plus N3 plus 3/2,
where these are the three
number operators, and 0.
Now, just for you to realize,
in the language of things
that we've been doing,
what is the state space?
If we call H1 the state space
of a one dimensional SHO,
what is the state space of
the three dimensional SHO?
Well, conceptually, how do you
build a three dimensional SHO?
Well, you have the creation
annihilation operators
that you had for
the x, y, and z.
So you have the ax dagger, the
ay dagger, and the az dagger,
and you could act on the vacuum.
So the way you can think of
the state space of the one
dimensional oscillator is this
is one dimensional oscillator
and I have all these things.
Here is the other
one dimensional,
here is the last
one dimensional.
But if I want to build a
state of the three dimensional
oscillator, I have to say how
many ax's, how many ay's, how
many az's.
So you're really
multiplying the states
in the sense of tensor products.
So the H, for a 3D SHO,
is the tensor product
of three H1's, the H1
x, the 1y, and the z.
You're really multiplying
all the states together.
Yes?
AUDIENCE: So this is
generalized to when
you have a wave function
that's separable into products
of different coordinates.
Can you express those
as tensor products
of the different
states, basically?
BARTON ZWIEBACH: You
see, the separable
into different coordinates,
it's yet another thing
because it would be the
question of whether the state is
separable or is entangled.
If you choose, for example,
one term like that,
a1, x, ax dagger, ay dagger, az
dagger, with two of those here,
the wave function is the product
of an x wave function, a y wave
function, and a z wave function.
But if you add to this ax
dagger squared plus ay plus az,
it will also be factorable,
but the sum is not factorable.
So you get the
entanglement kind of thing.
So this is the general
thing, and the basis vectors
of this tensor product are
basis vectors of one times basis
vectors of the
other basis vector.
So basically, one
basis vector here,
you pick some number of ax's,
some number of ay's, some
number of az's.
So this shows,
and it's a point I
want to emphasize
at this moment,
it's very important, that even
though we started thinking
of tensor products of
two particles, here,
there are no two particles in
the three dimensional harmonic
oscillator, no three particles.
There's just one particle where
there's one kind of attribute
that that's doing in
the x direction, one
kind of attribute
that it's doing
in the y, one kind of attribute
that it's doing in the z.
And therefore, you
need data for each one,
and the right data is
the tensor product.
You're just combining
them together.
We mentioned that the basis
vectors of a tensor product
are the products of
those basis vectors,
of each one, so that's exactly
how you build states here.
So I think, actually, you
probably have this intuition.
I just wanted to make it a
little more explicit for you.
So you don't need to
have two particles
to get a tensor product.
It can happen in simpler cases.
So here's the thing that
I want to do with you.
I would like to find that
diagram for the three
dimensional SHO.
That's our goal that we're
going to spend the next 15
minutes probably doing.
How does that diagram look?
So I'll put it somewhere
here maybe, or maybe here.
I won't need such a big diagram.
So I'll have it here.
Here is l, and here
are the energies.
So ground states.
The ground state, you can think
of it as a state like that.
How should I write it?
A state like that.
No oscillators acting on it
whatsoever, so the N's are N1
equals N2 equals N3
equals 0, and you
get E equals h bar
omega times 3/2.
So 3/2 h bar omega.
So actually, we got one state,
and it's the lowest energy
state.
Energy lowest possible.
So let me write here, energy
equals 3/2 h bar omega.
We got one state over here.
Now, can it be an l
equals 1 state or an l
equals 2 state or
an l equals 3 state?
How much is l for that state?
You see, if it's a
spherically symmetric problem,
it has to give you
a table like that.
It's guaranteed by angular
momentum, so we must find.
My question is whether it's l
equals 0, 1, 2, 3, or whatever.
Anybody would like to say
what do they think it is?
Kevin?
AUDIENCE: It's 0, right?
BARTON ZWIEBACH: 0.
And why?
AUDIENCE: Because we
wrote the operator for l
in terms of ax, ay, and az, and
you need one to be non-zero.
You need a difference between
them to generate a rotation.
BARTON ZWIEBACH:
OK, that's true.
It's a good answer.
It's very explicit.
Let me say it some other
way, why it couldn't possibly
be l equals 1.
Yes?
AUDIENCE: Because
the ground state
decreases for l decreasing.
BARTON ZWIEBACH: The ground
state energy does what?
AUDIENCE: It's
smaller for smaller l,
and so for l equals 0, you
have to have a smaller ground
state than for l equals 1.
BARTON ZWIEBACH: That's true.
Absolutely true.
The energy increases so
it cannot be l equals 1,
because then there will
be something below which
doesn't exist.
But there may be a
more plain answer.
AUDIENCE: The state
is non-degenerative.
BARTON ZWIEBACH: Yes.
There's just one state here.
We built one state.
If it would be l equals 1,
there should be three states
because l equals 1 comes with
m equals 1, 0, and minus 1.
So unless there are three
states, you cannot have that.
All right.
So then we go to the next level.
So I can build a state with
ax dagger on the vacuum,
a state with ay
dagger on the vacuum,
and a state with az
dagger on the vacuum
using one oscillator.
Here, the N's are
1, different ones,
and the energy is h bar
omega 1 plus 3/2, so 5/2.
And I got three states.
What can that be?
Well, could it be three
states of l equals 0?
No.
We said there's never
a degeneracy here.
There's always one thing, so
there would be one state here,
one state here, one
state here maybe.
We don't know, but they would
not have the same energy,
so it cannot be l equals 0.
Now, you probably remember that
l equals 1 has three states.
So without doing
any computation,
I think I can argue that
this must be l equals 1.
That cannot be any other thing.
It cannot be l equals 2
because you need five states.
Cannot be anything
with l equals 0.
So it must be l equals 1.
So here is l equals 0,
and here is l equals 1,
and there's no state here, but
there's one at 5/2 h bar omega.
So we obtain one state here.
And this corresponds
to a degeneracy.
This must correspond to l equals
1 because it's three states.
And that degeneracy
is totally explained
by angular momentum's
central potential.
It has to group in that way.
Of course, if my oscillator
had not been isotopic,
it would not group that way.
So we've got that one and we're,
I think, reasonably happy.
Now, let's list the various l's.
l equals 0, l equals 1,
l equals 2, l equals 3,
l equals 4, l equals 5.
How many states?
1, 3, 5, 7, 9, 11.
OK, good enough.
So we succeeded, so let's
proceed to one more level.
Let's see how we do.
Here, I would have
ax dagger squared
on the vacuum, ay dagger
squared on the vacuum, az
dagger squared on the vacuum.
Three states, but then
I have three more,
ax ay, both dagger on the
vacuum, ax az, and ay az,
for a total of six states.
So at N equals 2,
the next level,
let's call N equals
N1 plus N2 plus N3.
So this is N equals 2.
This is N equals 1.
You've got six states.
They must organize themselves
into representations
of angular momentum, so they
must be billed by these things.
So I cannot have l equals 3.
I don't have that many states.
I could have two l equals
1 states, three and three.
That would give six states,
or a five and a one.
So what are we looking at?
Let's see what we could have.
Well, we're trying to figure
out the next level, which
is 7/2 h bar omega.
If I say this is built
by two l equals 1's, I
would have to put two things
here, and that's wrong.
There cannot be two
multiplates at the same energy.
So even though it looks like you
could build it with two l equal
1's, you cannot.
So it must be an l equals
2 and an l equals 0.
So l equals 2 plus l equals
0, this one giving you
five states and this
giving you one state.
So at the next level,
this cannot be,
but what you get
instead, l equals 2.
You get one state here
and one state there.
This is already something a
little strange and unexpected.
For the first time,
you've got things
in different columns that
are matching together.
Why would these ones
match with these ones?
That requires an explanation.
You will see that explanation
a little later in the course,
and that's something
we need to understand.
So far, so good.
We seem to be making
good progress.
Let's do one more.
In fact, we need to
do maybe a couple more
to see the whole pattern.
Let's do the next
one, N total equals 3.
And now you have-- I'll be very
brief-- ax cubed, ay cubed, az
cubed, ax squared times ay or
az, ay squared times ax or az,
and az squared times ay or ax,
and ax ay az, all different.
And that builds for three
states here, two states here,
two states here, two states
here, and one state here.
So that's 10 states.
Yes?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]?
BARTON ZWIEBACH: No.
It's just laziness.
I just should have
put ax squared
ay dagger or ax
squared az squared.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]?
BARTON ZWIEBACH:
No, this is a sum.
This is what we used to call
the direct sum of vector spaces.
This is not the product.
That's pretty important.
Here, it's a sum.
We're saying 6 is 5
plus 1, basically.
Six states are five
vectors plus one vector.
Now, it can seem
a little confusing
because-- well,
it's not confusing.
If it would be a product, it
would be 1 times 5, which is 5.
So here, it's 6.
It's a direct sum.
It's saying the space
of states at this level
is six dimensional.
This is a five
dimensional vector space,
this is a one
dimensional vector space.
This is a direct sum,
something we defined
a month ago or two
months ago, direct sums.
So this is funny how
this is happening.
This tensor product is giving
you direct sums of states.
Anyway, 10 states here.
And now it does look like we
finally have an ambiguity.
We could have l equals 4, which
is nine states, plus l equals
0.
You cannot use any
one more than once.
We've learned that
for any energy level,
we cannot have some l appear
more than once because it would
imply degeneracy.
So I cannot build
this with 10 singlets,
or three l equal 1's
and one l equals 0.
I have to build it
with different things,
but I can build it as 9
plus 1, or I can build it
as l equals 3 plus l equals 1.
And the question
is, which one is it?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
BARTON ZWIEBACH: 3
and 1, is that right?
How would you see that?
AUDIENCE: Because the
lowest energy with l3
has to be lower than the
lowest energy with l4.
BARTON ZWIEBACH: Yes.
Indeed, it would
be very strange.
It shouldn't happen.
The energies are
sort of in units,
so here is l3 and
here is l equals 4.
If l4 would be here,
where could be l3?
It cannot be at a lower energy.
We've accounted
for all of those.
This is terribly unlikely,
and it must be this.
And therefore, you found here
next level, 9/2 h bar omega,
you got l equals 3, l equals 1.
It's possible to count.
You start to get bored
counting these things.
So if you had to count,
for example, the number
of states with 4, how would
you count them a little easier?
Well, you say, I need ax dagger
to the nx, ay dagger to the ny,
and az dagger to the nz.
That's the state.
And you must have nx
plus ny plus nz equals 4.
And you can plot this,
make a little diagram
like this, in which
you put nx, ny, and nz.
And you say, well, this
can be as far as 4,
this can be as high as 4,
so you have triangle,
but you only
have the integer solutions.
nx plus ny plus nz equals 4 is
that whole hyperplane, but only
integers and positive one.
So you have here, for
example, a solution.
This line is when nz
plus ny is equal to 4.
So here's nz equals 4,
nz equals 3, 2, 1, 0.
These are solutions.
Here, you have
just one solution.
Then you would have
two solutions here,
three solutions here,
four here, and five there.
So the number of states
is actually 1 plus 2
plus 3 plus 4 plus 5.
The number of states is
1 plus 2 plus 3 plus 4
plus 5, which is 15.
And you don't have
to write them.
So 15 states, what could it be?
Well, you go through
the numerology
and there seem to be several
options, but not too many
that make sense.
You could have something
with l equals 5,
but by the same
argument, it's unlikely.
But you could have
something with l equals 4
and begin with it.
So it must be an l equals 4,
which gives me already nine
states, and there are
left with six states.
But you know that with
six states, pretty much
the only thing you can do is
l equals 2 and l equals 0,
so that must be it.
The next state here,
l equals 4, is here.
This was 11/2 h bar omega,
and then it goes 4, 2, 0.
Enough to see the
pattern, I think.
You could do the next one.
Now it's quick because you
just need to add 6 here.
It adds one more,
so it's 21 states,
and you can see
what can you build.
But it does look like
you have this, this,
and that you jump by two units.
So you have 0, then
1, and nothing.
Then 2, and you
jump the next to 0.
And then 3 is the next one, and
then you jump 2, and that's it.
And here, jump 2 and jump 2.
So in jumps of 2, you go to the
angular momentum that you need.
So how can you
understand a little more
of what's going on here?
Why these things?
Well, as you may recall, we
used to have this discussion
in which you have an a x and ay.
You could trade for
a right and a left.
And with those, the angular
momentum in the z-direction
was h bar N right minus N left.
This is for a
two-dimensional oscillator,
but the x and y of the
three-dimensional oscillator
works exactly the same way.
So Lz is nicely written in
terms of these variables.
And it takes a little more
work to get the other-- the Lx
and Ly, but they
can be calculated.
And they correspond
to the true angular
momentum of this particle.
It's the real angular momentum.
It's not the angular
momentum that you
found for the two-dimensional
harmonic oscillator.
It's the real one.
So here we go with
a little analysis.
How would you build now
states in this language?
You can understand things
better in this case
because, for example,
for N equals 1,
you could have a
state a right dagger
on the vacuum, a z dagger,
a left dagger on the vacuum.
And then you can say, what
is the Lz of this state?
Well, a right dagger on the
vacuum has Lz equal h bar.
This has 0 because
Lz doesn't depend
on the z-component
of the oscillator.
And this has minus h bar.
So here you see actually,
the whole structure of the L
equal 1 multiplet.
We said that we have at
this level L equals 1.
And indeed, for L equals
1, you expect the state
with Lz equal plus
1, 0, and minus 1.
So you see the whole thing.
For n equals 2, what do you get?
Well, you see a state, for
example, of a right dagger
a right dagger on the vacuum.
And that has Lz equals 2 h bar.
And therefore, you must have--
since you cannot have states
with higher Lz, you cannot
have a state, for example,
here with Lz equal 3.
So you cannot have an L equal 3.
In fact, for any N
that you build states,
you can only get
states with whatever
N is is the maximum
value that Lz can have,
which is something I want to
illustrate just generically
for a second.
So in order to show that, let
me go back here and exhibit
for you a little of
the general structure.
So suppose you're building
now with N equal n.
The total number
is N. So you have
a state with a right dagger
to the n on the vacuum.
And this is the state
with highest possible Lz
because all the
oscillators are aR dagger.
So Lz is the highest.
And highest Lz is,
in fact, n h bar.
Now, let's try to build a state
with a little bit less Lz.
You see, if this is
a multiplet, this
has to be a multiplet with some
amount of angular momentum.
So it's going to go from
Lz equal n, n minus 1,
up to minus n.
There are going to be 2n plus
1 states of this much angular
momentum because this
has to be a multiplet.
So here you have a
state with one unit
less of angular momentum, a
right dagger to the n minus 1,
times an az dagger.
I claim that's the
only state that you
can build with one
unit less of angular
momentum in the
z-direction because I've
traded this aR for an az.
So this must be the second
state in the multiplet.
This multiplet with
highest value of L,
which is equal to n, corresponds
to an angular momentum l,
little l, equals n.
And then, it must have
this 2n plus 1 states.
And here is the second state.
So this is Lz equals nh bar.
And here, n minus 1 h bar.
And I don't think there's any
other state at that level.
Let's lower the angular
momentum once more.
So what do we get?
a right dagger n minus
2 az dagger squared.
That's another state with
one less angular momentum
than this.
This, in fact, has n
minus 2 times h bar.
Now, is that the
unique state that I
can have with two units
less of angular momentum?
No.
What is the other one?
AUDIENCE: aR to
the n minus 1 a l?
PROFESSOR: Correct,
that lowers it.
third so here you have aR to the
n minus 1 a left on the vacuum.
That's another state with two
units less of angular momentum.
So in this situation, a
funny thing has happened.
And here's why you
understand the jump of 2.
This state, you
actually-- if you're
trying to build this
multiplet, now you
have two states that have
the same value of Lz.
And you actually don't
know whether the next state
in the multiplet
is this, or that,
or some linear combination.
It better be some
linear combination.
But the fact is that at this
level, you found another state.
So this multiplet
will go on and it
will be some linear combination.
Maybe this diagram
doesn't illustrate that.
But then you will have
another state here.
So some other linear combination
that builds another multiplet.
And this multiplet has two
units less of angular momentum.
And that explains why
this diagram always jumps.
It always jumps 2.
And you could do that here.
If you tried to write
the next things here,
you will find two states
that you can write.
But if you go one lower,
you will find three states.
Which means that
at the next level,
you built another-- you
need another state with two
units less of angular
momentum each time.
So pretty much that's it.
That illustrates how
this diagram happens.
The only thing we
haven't answered,
and you will see
that in an exercise,
how could I have understood
from the beginning
that this would have happened
rather than building it
this way that
there's this thing?
And what you will
find is that there's
some operators that commute
with the Hamiltonian that
move you from here to here.
And that explains it all.
Because if you have an
operator that commutes with
the Hamiltonian, it
cannot change the energy.
And if it changes the value of
L, it explains why it happened.
So that's something that
you need to discover,
what are these operators.
I can give you a hint.
An operator for the
type ax dagger ay
destroys a y oscillator,
creates an x one.
It doesn't change the energy
because it adds one thing
and loses one.
So this kind of thing must
commute with the Hamiltonian.
And these are the
kind of objects--
there are lots of them.
So surprising new things that
commute with the Hamiltonian.
And there's a whole
hidden symmetry in here
that is generated by
operators of this form.
So it's something you will see.
Now, the last 15 minutes
I want to show you
what happens with hydrogen.
There's a similar
phenomenon there
that we're going to try
to explain in detail.
So a couple of things
about hydrogen.
So hydrogen H is
equal to p squared
over 2m minus e squared over r.
There's a natural length scale
that people many times struggle
to find it, the Bohr radius.
This does it come from here?
How do you see immediately
what is the Bohr radius?
Well, the Bohr radius can
be estimated by saying,
well, this is an energy but it
must be similar to this energy.
So p is like h over a distance.
So let's call it a0.
So that's p squared.
m is the reduced mass of the
proton electron system roughly
equal to the electron mass.
And then you set it
equal to this one
because you're just doing units.
You want to find the quantity
that has units of length
and there you got it.
That's the famous Bohr radius.
p is h bar over a
distance, therefore
this thing must be an energy.
It must be equal to this.
And from this one,
you can solve for a0.
It's h squared over m e squared.
The 1 over e squared is
very famous and important.
It reflects the
fact that if you had
the interaction
between the electron
and the proton go to 0, the
radius would be infinite.
As it becomes weaker and
weaker the interaction,
the radius of the
hydrogen atom blows up.
So this is about
0.529 angstroms,
where an angstrom is 10
to the minus 10 meters.
And what is the energy scale?
Well, e squared over a0 is
the energy scale, roughly.
And in fact, e squared
over 2a 0, if you wish,
is a famous number.
It's about 13.6 ev.
So how about the spectrum?
And how do you find that?
Well, there's one
nice way of doing
this, which you will
see in the problem,
to find at least
the ground state.
And it's a very elegant
way based on factorization.
Let we mention it.
It is called Hamiltonian.
It can be written as a
constant gamma plus 1
over 2m sum over k pk plus i
beta xk over r times pk minus i
beta xk over r.
It's a factorized version of the
Hamiltonian of a hydrogen atom.
Apparently, not a
well-known result.
Professor [? Jackiw ?]
mentioned it to me.
I don't think I've
seen it in any book.
So there's a constant
beta and a constant gamma
for which this becomes
exactly that one.
So gamma and beta
to be determined.
And you have to be a
little careful here
when you expand that this term
and this term don't commute.
And this and this don't commute.
But after you're
done, it comes out.
And then, the ground
state wave function
is-- since this is an
operator and here it's dagger,
the ground state wave function
is-- the lowest possible energy
wave function is
one in which this
would kill the wave function.
So pk minus i beta xk over r
should kill the ground state
wave function.
And then the energy,
E ground, would
be equal to precisely
this constant gamma.
And you will show, in fact,
that yes, this has a solution.
And that's the
ground state energy
of the oscillator of the
hydrogen atom, of course.
So this looks like three
equations, pk with k
equals 1 to 3.
But it reduces to 1 if the
state is spherically symmetric.
So it's a nice thing and
it gives you the answer.
Now, the whole spectrum
of the hydrogen atom
is as interestingly
degenerate as one
of the three-dimensional
harmonic oscillator.
And a reminder of it is
that-- should I go here?
Yes.
You have here energies
and here l's. l
equals 0 you have one state.
l equals 1 you have
another state that's here.
But actually, l equals 0
will have another state.
And then it goes on like
that, another state here,
state here, state
here for l equals 2.
And the first state is here.
The first state of this
one aligns with this one.
The first state of
that aligns with that.
So they go like
that, the states just
continue to go exactly
with this symmetry.
So let me use label
that is common,
to call this the state nu
equals 0 for L equals 0.
Nu equals 1.
Nu equals 2.
Nu equals 3.
This is the first state
with L equals 1 is here.
So we'll call it nu equals 0.
Nu equals 1.
New equals 2.
The first state here is
nu equals 0, nu equals 1.
And then the energies.
You define n to be
nu plus l plus 1.
Therefore, this
corresponds to n equals 1.
This corresponds to n equals 2.
That corresponds to nu can be
1 and l equals 0 or nu can be 0
and l equals 1.
This is n equal 3,
and things like that.
And then the energies
of those states, nl
is, in fact, minus z squared.
Well, forget the z squared.
e squared over 2 a0
1 over n squared.
So the only thing
that happens is
that there's a degeneracy,
complete degeneracy.
Very powerful degeneracy.
And then, l can only run up
to-- from 0, 1, up to n minus 1
in these variables.
So this is the
picture of hydrogen.
So you've seen several pictures
already-- the square well,
the three-dimensional
harmonic oscillator,
and the hydrogen one.
Each one has a
different picture.
Now, in order to
understand this one--
this one is not that difficult.
But the one of the hydrogen
is really more interesting.
It all originates
with the idea of what
is called the
Runge-Lenz vector, which
I'm going to use the last
five minutes to introduce.
And think about it a little.
So it comes from
classical mechanics.
So we have an elliptical
orbit, orbits,
and people figured out
there was something
very funny about characterizing
elliptical orbit.
So consider a
Hamiltonian, which is p
squared over 2m plus
v of r, a potential.
The force, classically,
would be minus the gradient
of the potential, which is minus
the derivative of the potential
with respect to r times
the r unit vector.
Now classically-- this
all begins classically.
Except for spin 1/2
systems, classical physics
really tells you a lot
of what's going on.
So classically, dp dt is
the force and it's minus v
prime over r r vector over r.
And dl dt, the angular momentum,
it's a central potential.
The angular momentum is 0.
It's rate of change is 0.
There's no torque on the
particle, so this should be 0.
Now, the interesting
thing that happens
is that this doesn't
exhaust the kind of things
that are, in fact, conserved.
So there is something
more that is conserved.
And it's a very
surprising quantity.
It's so surprising
that people have
a hard time
imagining what it is.
I will write it down and show
you how it sort of happens.
Well, you have to
begin with p cross L.
Why you would think of p cross
l is a little bit of a mystery,
but it's an interesting thing.
Now, here is a computation
that will be in the notes
that you can try doing.
And it takes a little bit
of work, but it's algebra.
If you compute this and
do a fair amount of work,
like five, six lines--
I would suspect it's
fairly non-trivial
to do it if you
don't see how it's
being done, but it
will be in the notes-- you
get the following thing.
Just by manipulating the
time derivative of p cross L,
you get this.
Which is equal to m times
the potential differentiator
times r squared times the
time derivative of this.
So time derivative,
time derivative.
You can get the conservation
if this is a constant.
So when is this a constant?
If this is some
constant, say, e squared,
you would get a conservation.
But what is v prime equals
e squared over r squared?
It would give you that v
of r is essentially minus
e squared over r.
That's the potential
of hydrogen.
Or the 1 over r potential, 1
over r squared force field.
So in 1 over r potentials,
this is a number.
And then you get an incredible
conservation law, d dt
of p cross L minus m e squared
r hat over r is equal to 0.
So something fairly unexpected
that something like this
could be conserved.
So actually, you can try
to figure out what this is.
And there's two neat--
first, one thing
that people do,
which is convenient,
is to make this into
unit-free vector.
So define R to be p
cross L over m e squared
minus r vector over r.
This has no units.
And it's supposed
to be conserved.
Now, one thing you will
check in the homework
is that this is conserved
quantum mechanically as well.
That is, this is
an operator that
commutes with a Hamiltonian.
Very interesting calculation.
This is a Hermitian
operator, so you
will have to Hermiticize
the p cross L to do that.
But it will commute
with the Hamiltonian.
But what I want to finish
now is with your intuition
as to what this is.
And this was a very interesting
discovery, this vector.
In fact, people
didn't appreciate
what was the role of this
vector for quite some time.
So apparently, it was discovered
and forgotten, and discovered
and forgotten like
two or three times.
And for us, it's going to
be quite crucial because I
said to you that this operator
commutes with the Hamiltonian.
So actually, you will
get conservation laws
and will help us explain the
degeneracy of the hydrogen
atom.
So it will be very
important for us.
Now, how does this look?
First of all, if you
had a circular orbit,
how does it work?
Have a circular orbit.
Let's see, p is here,
L is out of the board.
p cross L is here
over m e squared.
And the radial vector
is here, the hat vector.
So the sum of these two vectors
p cross L and the radial vector
must be conserved.
But how could it be?
If they don't cancel, it
either points in or points out.
And then it would just rotate
and it would not be conserved.
So actually, for a circular
orbit, you can calculate it.
See the notes.
Actually, it's an
easy calculation.
And you can verify that this
vector is, in fact, precisely
opposite this.
And it's 0.
So you say, great.
You discover something that
is conserved, but it's 0.
No.
The thing is that this thing is
not 0 for an elliptical orbit.
So how can you see that?
Well here at this
point, p is up here.
L is out.
And p cross L, just like
before, is out and r hat is in.
And you say, well, OK.
Now the same problem.
If they don't cancel,
it's going to be a vector
and going to rotate.
But it has to be conserved.
So actually, let's
look at it here.
Here, the main
thing of an ellipse,
if you have the focus here,
is that this line is not--
the tangent is not horizontal.
So the momentum is here.
L is out of the blackboard,
but p cross L now is like that.
And the radial vector is here.
And they don't cancel.
So the only thing
that can happen--
since this is vertical,
this is vertical.
It's a little bit to the left--
is that the r vector must
be a little vector
horizontal here.
Because the sum of this
vector and this vector--
it has to be horizontal.
Here we don't know
if they can cancel.
But if they don't cancel,
it's definitely horizontal.
We know it's conserved, so
it must be horizontal here.
So it points in.
So the Runge-Lenz
vector r points in.
And it's, in fact, that.
So here you go, this is a
vector that is conserved.
And its properties
that is really
about the axis of the ellipse.
It tells you where the axis is.
In Einstein's theory of gravity,
the potential is not 1/r
and the ellipsis [? precess ?]
and the Runge vector
is not conserved.
But in 1/r potentials,
it is conserved.
The final thing-- sorry
for taking so long--
is that the magnitude
of r is precisely
the eccentricity of the orbit.
So it's a really nice way
of characterizing the orbits
and we'll be using it
in the next lecture.
See you on Wednesday.